del espacio nos venimos acá a la
realidad económica de nuestro planeta
jorge hurtado ya está con nosotros aquí
en el estudio porque comenzamos en
europa porque el banco de inglaterra
subió los tipos de interés para intentar
frenar la inflación fenómeno mundial
bueno se trata del movimiento más
agresivo en 27 años que realiza este
emisor ahí el aumento de los precios de
la energía consecuencia de la invasión
rusa de ucrania los responsables de los
tipos de interés del banco de inglaterra
votaron 81 a favor de una subida de
medio punto porcentual del tipo de
interés bancario hasta el 1 75 por
ciento de su mayor subida de tipos de
interés desde el año 1995 al tiempo que
pronosticaron que la inflación superaría
el 13 por ciento este año la libra
esterlina cayó cuando el banco de
inglaterra dijo también que el reino
unido- entraría en recesión a finales de
2022 y no saldría de ella hasta
principios del año 2024 escuchamos
ahora esta subida de los precios de la
energía ha profundizado la caída de los
ingresos reales y por tanto ha provocado
otro deterioro significativo de las
perspectivas de la actividad en el reino
unido- y en el resto de europa el
crecimiento del pib en reino unido se ha
ralentizado y se prevé que la economía
entre en recesión a finales de este año
'jorge entretanto en italia aprobaron un
millonario presupuesto para que las
familias italianas y las empresas puedan
sobrellevar la inflación en este país se
trata santiago de un paquete de ayudas
de 17 mil 400 millones de dólares el es
el plan este plan es uno de los últimos
más importantes del primer ministro
saliente mario draghi antes de las
elecciones nacionales del próximo mes se
suman los 35 mil millones de euros
presupuestados desde enero para
amortiguar los altos costos de la
electricidad el gas y la gasolina un
borrador visto por la agencia reuters
también mostraba que el gobierno
extendería una bonificación de 200 euros
pagada a julio a los italianos de
ingresos bajos y medios para los
trabajadores que no la recibían también
el recorte de impuestos fue anunciado
este recorte impuestos especiales sobre
los combustibles que expiraba el 21 de
agosto
hasta el próximo 20 de septiembre y
pasamos a eeuu porque el presidente joe
biden también está impulsando que
busquen aprobar en el congreso una ley
de reducción de la inflación de qué se
trata este plan todos atacando lo mismo
la inflación y así en otro paquete
también de ayuda bastante millonario se
trata de un paquete de 739 mil millones
de dólares que puede ayudar a reducir la
inflación recortar el déficit
presupuestario a abordar el cambio
climático e inclusive reducir las
facturas médicas promete según el
presidente validen que este proyecto de
ley ahorrará a los estadounidenses y a
medicare cientos de miles de millones de
dólares al tiempo que sería la mayor
inversión jamás realizada en energía
limpia y en la seguridad energética pero
los legisladores republicanos argumentan
que en el impuesto mínimo de sociedades
del 15% incluido en el paquete afectaría
a las fábricas y a los trabajadores de
clase media de ese país ahora sin apoyo
republicano para ser aprobado este
acuerdo aún necesita el respaldo de las
senadoras cristian cinema demócrata de
arizona ya que el senado está dividido
en partes iguales donde regularmente
presidente kamala harris es la encargada
de realizar el desempate pues ya veremos
cuál es la votación allí en eeuu
mientras tanto en argentina el nuevo
superministro de economía masa ya dio a
conocer algunas de sus medidas cuáles
fueron las reacciones de los argentinos
pues en sus primeras medidas como
ministro masa ratificó la reducción del
déficit fiscal a 2,5 por ciento del pib
este año eso es algo que ya había sido
acordado con el fondo monetario
internacional asimismo se comprometió a
frenar la emisión monetaria y a limitar
los costosos subsidios a los servicios
públicos más anuncios incentivos a los
exportadores para aumentar ventas al
exterior y generar ingresos de divisas
por vía impositiva esto para tratar de
inyectar las reservas internacionales en
el banco central movimientos sociales y
analistas aún quedaron insatisfechos con
estos anuncios pero escuchamos que decía
la población para mí esto no resuelve
nada
quieren depositar toda la todo el
esfuerzo la argentina una persona como
si fuera a resolver algo y para mí no es
así y es una expectativa no es
lo mejor que nos puede pasar obviamente
que si llegamos a esta instancia es
porque las cosas no andan bien en donde
también hay reacciones es en cuba pero
ante el anuncio del gobierno de la isla
de comprar dólares en los mercados
extranjeros santiago de esa medida
empezó precisamente hoy y busca socavar
el mercado monetario informal y capturar
también los fondos el detalle es que la
isla compraría hasta cinco veces más
cara a la divisa americana la divisa se
disparó en el mercado negro después de
que en enero del 2021 el gobierno puso
en vigor una reforma financiera que fijó
el dólar en 24 pesos cubanos y ese mismo
año suspendió la venta de dólares a la
población debido a la falta de liquidez
ahora el sistema bancario estatal fijó
nuevamente esa tasa a 120 pesos por
dólar pero sólo la compran ciudadanos y
pequeñas empresas la noticia generó
reacciones en la isla escuchemos
y luego como un paso a lo mejor se quede
ahí
todo como evolucione bien sonido
hay muchas limitaciones
muy poco poder de adquisición de
productos necesarios de alimentación
sobre todo de aseo porque muchas gracias
por este reporte punto final en la
economía aquí en directo américa a
continuación el debate